[Music]
new technology revealed an ancient
civilization in Central America may have
been several times bigger and much more
complex and archaeologists believe
scientists say they use lasers to expose
previously unknown Mayan cities and
thousands of structures the high-tech
mapping surveyed about 800 square miles
of Guatemala David Berg know is here
with what we're learning about this
mysterious civilization David good
morning to you it's interesting Gail
good morning explorers would spend days
trekking through the hot and dangerous
jungles of Guatemala looking for Mayan
ruins now within seconds new technology
is helping them pinpoint thousands of
hidden archaeological treasures they
didn't even know existed
Indiana Jones could have only dreamed of
this
archeologists are using high-level
mapping technology to virtually unearth
a massive network of Mayan ruins hidden
for centuries in the thick jungles of
Guatemala Albert Lin is an engineer and
National Geographic Explorer who worked
on a television special about the
breakthrough so we had this augmented
reality platform built based off in the
lidar data you know it says there's a
massive temple just around the corner
all right gives you chills up your back
the uncovered landscape includes
previously unknown cities and more than
60,000 interconnected structures
including houses farms highways and even
pyramids scientists and archaeologists
discovered the ruins by shooting lasers
down from a plane to penetrate the dense
jungle canopy the technology is called
light detection and ranging or lidar
Marian Hernandez is president of
Pakenham the Guatemalan nonprofit that
started the project to uncover more of
the Mayan civilization
it will provide empirical proof of the
sophistication and complexity of their
settlement systems Francisco Estrada
belly is co-director of the PACU Nam
project
he says lidar technology is
revolutionizing archaeology quite like
the Hubble telescope revolutionized
astronomy when they started looking at
through that telescope they found
thousands of galaxies and that's what
we're seeing were part of the jungle we
thought there were empty are full of CDs
and small towns and amazing things that
we didn't suspect were there so previous
assessments estimated just one or two
million people lived in the Mayan
lowlands but now researchers believe as
many as 20 million people may have lived
there you can watch lost treasures of
the Mayans snake Kings this Tuesday on
National Geographic I love that kind of
stuff wow that's one to record for the
kids I agree I love those discoveries
hidden for so long well the researchers
said they had been walking essentially
walking on the but never noticed them
until they started looking
from the air super laser though and they
found that secret room in the Great
Pyramid it's great
thanks David David nerd alert I'm gonna
watch it let's watch it together Nora
[Laughter]